Jake: 好可惜啊
Jake: What a pity
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Jake: 这要怎么抓
Jake: How do we catch this?
Jake: 这好抓吗
Jake: Is it easy to catch?
Tasha: 不好抓吧
Tasha: Not easy, right?
Tasha: 你觉得好抓吗
Tasha: Do you think it's easy to catch?
Jake: 抓一个我不知道
Jake: Catch one, I don't know
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Tasha: 走哈哈啊
Tasha: Let's go haha
Jake: 会抓吗
Jake: Can you catch it?
Tasha: 最后一下
Tasha: One last try
Jake: 这个这这是不是很难抓呀
Jake: Is this very hard to catch?
Tasha: 这种很难抓啊
Tasha: This kind is very hard to catch
Jake: 这个好大好大
Jake: This one is so big
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Alice:给你一点甜头
Alice: Give you a little taste
Alice:让你觉得离他近在咫尺
Alice: Make you feel it's within reach
Tasha: 对我想去
Tasha: Yeah, I want to go
Jake: 对开心一会
Jake: Yeah, happy for a while
Jake: 开心个5秒
Jake: Happy for 5 seconds
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Jake:你要玩吗
Jake: Do you want to play?
Tasha: 我没有带手套哎
Tasha: I didn't bring gloves
Tasha: 你看他们都要戴手套玩
Tasha: Look, they all need to wear gloves to play
Jake: 摩手是吧
Jake: Rub hands, right?
Tasha: 没有币了是吗啊
Tasha: We're out of coins, right?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 没有币了
Tasha: No more coins.
Jake: 没有币了
Jake: No more coins.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake: 币用光了吗
Jake: Are we out of coins?
Jake: 还是还有
Jake: Or do we still have some?
Jake: 还有最后一个
Jake: We have one last coin.
Shure:  还有最后一个
Shure: We have one last coin.
Jake: 还有一个币
Jake: We have one coin left.
Jake: 能干嘛
Jake: What can we do with it?
Jake: 这个啊这这一个币
Jake: This, uh, this one coin.
Jake: 我靠呵呵呵
Jake: Oh my gosh, hahaha.
Alice:真是一个币
Alice: It's really one coin.
Jake: 我靠真的
Jake: Oh my gosh, really.
Jake: 好看你表演吧
Jake: Alright, let's see you perform.
Tasha: 我也不会玩
Tasha: I don't know how to play either.
Jake: 路亚那边有几个币他人呢
Jake: How many coins does Lua have over there, where is he?
Alice:露西亚呢
Alice: Where's Lucia?
Tasha: （歌词）当我遇见你了
Tasha: (Lyrics) When I met you
Tasha: 靠怎么今天才发货
Tasha: Gosh, why did it ship today?
Jake: 你那个币是怎么花的呀
Jake: How did you spend that coin?
Jake: 还没花了
Jake: Haven't spent it yet?
Jake: 可以捐了一毛
Jake: You can donate a dime.
Lucia: 然后我按开始吗
Lucia: Then do I press start?
Shure:  对你按开始
Shure: Yes, press start.
Jake: 现在还剩几个呀不剩了
Jake: How many are left now? None left.
Jake: 确实不剩了应该
Jake: There really shouldn't be any left.
Jake: 这个这个意思是
Jake: This, this means...
Jake: 这个意思是
Jake: This means...
Jake: 我再投一个币就可以算了吧
Jake: If I put in another coin, it'll be fine, right?
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Uh-huh.
Tasha: 投
Tasha: Put it in.
Jake: 好像不是哦
Jake: Seems like it's not.
Jake: 是啊那我就开始玩了
Jake: Yeah, okay, I'll start playing then.
Tasha: 不能一起玩吗
Tasha: Can't we play together?
Jake: 这啥意思啊
Jake: What does this mean?
Jake: 可以你你你先扔吧
Jake: Okay, you, you, you go first.
Tasha: 我不会你扔过吗
Tasha: I don't know how, have you thrown it before?
Jake: 我靠哦好吧
Jake: Oh my gosh, alright.
Jake: 他就是给你一个模拟
Jake: He's just giving you a simulation.
Tasha: 哦我扔掉了两个球
Tasha: Oh, I threw away two balls.
Jake: 那你可能你现在要把
Jake: Then maybe now you need to...
Jake: 你还有一轮
Jake: You still have one more round.
Jake: 你要把剩下的给干掉
Jake: You need to knock out the rest.
Tasha: 真的吗对那
Tasha: Really? Okay.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 保龄球就是这样
Jake: That's how bowling works.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake: 就是每人有两个机会
Jake: Everyone gets two chances.
Jake: 然后你争取这两轮就把他给全部干掉
Jake: And you try to knock down all the pins in those two rounds.
Tasha: 为什么我老是这样子
Tasha: Why do I always mess up like this?
Jake: 我来展示一下
Jake: Let me show you.
Tasha: 好您您来
Tasha: Okay, you go ahead.
Jake: 但是我我可能哎他哦
Jake: But I might... oh, if it hits both sides, it should go down.
Jake: 他两边如果碰到应该就下去了
Jake: If it hits both sides, it should go down.
Jake:它还是
Jake: It's still...
Tasha: 有什么了不起的哈哈哈
Tasha: What's so great about that? Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈请
Jake: Hahaha, please.
Jake: 火鸡大奖啊
Jake: Turkey prize!
Jake: 这个还可以扔
Jake: You can still throw this.
Jake: 啥意思啊
Jake: What does this mean?
Jake: 能干嘛呀
Jake: What's it for?
Tasha: 彩票哦我猜的
Tasha: Lottery, I guess.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 没有请
Jake: No, please.
Tasha: 怎么怎么来
Tasha: How do you do it?
Jake: 就唉我靠
Jake: Just... oh, come on!
Jake: 怎么玩就这样嘛
Jake: Just like this, keep your shoulders straight.
Jake: 就这样然后肩得平肩得平
Jake: Like this, keep your shoulders straight.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 肩得平啊
Tasha: Shoulders straight, huh?
Jake: 对不过
Jake: Yeah, but...
Jake: 哎呀我去啊
Jake: Oh my god.
Tasha: 哎呀我去
Tasha: Oh my god.
Jake: 没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake: 你还有一次
Jake: You have one more try.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake: 好点好点
Jake: A bit better, a bit better.
Tasha: 不你来吧
Tasha: No, you go ahead.
Jake: 你来你来你来
Jake: You come, you come, you come.
Jake: 哦这个这个好
Jake: Oh, this one, this one is good.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake: 来你的火鸡大奖
Jake: Here is your turkey grand prize.
Jake: 这一块钱花的值
Jake: This one dollar was well spent.
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈问题不大
Jake: Hahaha, it's not a big problem.
Jake: 因为他右边也很多哈哈
Jake: Because there's a lot on the right side too, haha.
Jake: 我觉得你真到哪都没什么关系啊
Jake: I think it really doesn't matter where you go.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake: 你真到哪都没什么关系
Jake: It really doesn't matter where you go.
Tasha: 就比你少了一拼
Tasha: Just a little less than you.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Tasha: 这一块钱花的值
Tasha: This one dollar was well spent.
Jake: 是还有
Jake: Yes, there's more.
Tasha: 还有啊你呢哈哈哈
Tasha: There's more, and you, haha.
Jake: 这太值了吧我靠
Jake: This is too worth it, oh my gosh.
Jake: 还还有那种花火
Jake: There's also those fireworks.
Jake: 哎我靠
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 好滑
Tasha: So slippery.
Jake: 这已经这已经下去了
Jake: It's already gone down.
Tasha: 两瓶
Tasha: Two bottles.
Jake: 哈哈哈再来再来
Jake: Hahaha, come on, come on again.
Jake: 不过这个有点离谱
Jake: But this one is a bit absurd.
Jake: 就是这个
Jake: It's just this.
Jake: 因为因为他和现实不一样
Jake: Because it's different from reality.
Jake: 所以我可以直接砸过去
Jake: So I can just throw it over.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake: 就像这样
Jake: Just like this.
Jake: 哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha, ah.
Tasha: 咦
Tasha: Ew.
Tasha: 补中
Tasha: Got it.
Jake: 补中
Jake: Got it.
Tasha: 火鸡大奖
Tasha: Turkey grand prize.
Jake: 没有再来
Jake: No, try again.
Tasha: 必须要一把全部击中才能火鸡大奖吗
Tasha: Do you have to hit all of them in one go to get the turkey grand prize?
Jake: 好像是对对对
Jake: Seems like it, yes, yes, yes.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 哦总分已经出来了呀
Tasha: Oh, the total score is already out.
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha: OK OK
Jake: OK欢迎
Tasha: 值值
Jake: 值
Jake: 太值了这一块钱我再来收
Jake: 呃但是一个币都没有了
Tasha: 那还有一个币可以玩啊
Tasha: 射蓝我也挺喜欢玩的
Jake: 收获满满
Shure:  就他抓到了是吗
Jake: 对还好还好有个东西证明我们来过
Jake: 不然这一段可能就撵不上
Jake: 对对对然后问这哪来的对
Lucia: 还有谁要抓娃娃吗
Lucia: 我刚拿了大概15个的样子还有仨
Tasha: 哈
Lucia: 对我刚对
Jake: 还有啊
Lucia: 我刚拿了大概15个的样子
Lucia: 居然还有仨
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 还有还有三个
Jake: There's still three more.
Lucia: 可能因为我一直都在玩那些游戏
Lucia: Maybe because I've been playing those games all the time.
Lucia: 花的时间很久
Lucia: It takes a long time.
Lucia: 所以他现在还有三个
Lucia: So he still has three left.
Shure:  我们我们用钱生钱
Shure: We're making money with money.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright.
Lucia: 这能推下来吗
Lucia: Can this be pushed down?
Jake: 呃那边还有一个保龄球一块钱
Jake: Uh, there's still a bowling game over there for one dollar.
Jake: 玩了很久
Jake: Played for a long time.
Jake: 因为前面有个人投了两个币
Jake: Because someone in front put in two coins.
Jake: 还剩一个就可以玩
Jake: Just one left to play.
Jake: 然后我们在钱生钱这这这这这这
Jake: Then we're making money with money this this this this this.
Lucia: 然后我们在潜水
Lucia: Then we were diving.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 我玩那个节奏大师也是玩了好长时间
Lucia: I've also played Rhythm Master for a long time.
Tasha: 我也想玩节奏大师来着
Tasha: I also wanted to play Rhythm Master.
Lucia: 那要玩那个吗
Lucia: Do you want to play that?
Tasha: 币不够吧
Tasha: Don't we not have enough coins?
Lucia: 呃他好像也是投三个
Lucia: Uh, I think it also takes three.
Lucia: 然后然后那个
Jake: 我们就可以收位一下
Lucia: 反正投三个币可以玩我觉得
Lucia: 将近将近6分钟左右
Lucia: 所以我一直在玩那个
Tasha: 我也想玩来着
Lucia: 然后就导致我现在还有仨
Jake: 213
Jake: 买买买买个买个2/3 对
Jake: 2-32-3呢李凯有个神仙有个菩萨
Jake: 有个菩萨之前
Tasha: 这个刚刚是也投了俩
Jake: 对这个也是2/3
Jake: 这也是2/3
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: 神奇
Lucia: 谁先来
Jake: 来吧
Jake: 牛啊
Lucia: 哇居然是现实和屏幕结合
Jake: 哈哈哈是耶
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Lucia: 哇厉害
Lucia: Wow, amazing!
Shure:  strike全雷打懂吗
Shure: Do you understand a strike home run?
Jake: 来你还有一个
Jake: Come on, you have one more.
Katrina:  火鸡大奖
Katrina: Turkey grand prize!
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome!
Shure:  练过的练过
Shure: I've practiced, I've practiced.
Jake: 练过
Jake: Practiced.
Jake: 可以好下去吧
Jake: Alright, go on.
Jake: 哈哈哈换下一个
Jake: Hahaha, next one!
Lucia: 那我来好了
Lucia: Then I'll go.
Jake: 要拿要帮你拿东西吗
Jake: Do you need me to get anything for you?
Lucia: 就把它扔进去就行了吗
Lucia: Just throw it in, right?
Jake: 来
Jake: Go ahead.
Jake: 对就越中间越好
Jake: Yes, the more centered the better.
Lucia: 对就越中间越好
Lucia: Yes, the more centered the better.
Jake: 你还有5秒钟
Jake: You have 5 seconds left.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake: 那还你还有一次机会
Jake: You have one more chance.
Jake: 你可以往左边打一打
Jake: You can hit it to the left.
Lucia: 然后呢他会哎
Lucia: And then he will...
Tasha: 球
Tasha: Ball.
Jake: 球来了
Jake: The ball is coming.
Tasha: 补中
Tasha: Hit it!
Jake: 哈哈哈好
Jake: Hahaha, good.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Jake: 来吧
Jake: Come on.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Shure:  strike
Shure: Strike.
Jake: 上火鸡就一次
Jake: You only get a turkey once.
Jake: 全砸中就有个火鸡
Jake: If you hit them all, you get a turkey.
Jake: 哈哈没关系这左边右边都没有差别
Jake: Haha, it's okay, there's no difference between left and right.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Tasha: 啊我比你厉害哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah, I'm better than you, hahaha.
Jake: 越歪分越高你知道不
Jake: The more crooked, the higher the score, you know?
Shure:  来下一位
Shure: Next person.
Jake: 来来来来来来
Jake: Come on, come on, come on.
Shure:  你这好随意啊
Shure: You're so casual with this.
Jake: 哈哈手滑了
Jake: Haha, slipped.
Jake: 还有还有还有
Jake: There's more, more.
Shure:  哎你这
Shure: Hey, you...
Shure:  现实中你这就是Ghetto
Shure: In reality, this would be ghetto.
Katrina:  是一个很随便的人
Katrina: Such a casual person.
Jake: 球球来了
Jake: The ball is coming.
Jake: 球已经来了
Jake: The ball is here.
Katrina:  哦哦已经来了
Katrina: Oh, it's already here.
Katrina:  OK这也可以
Katrina: OK, this works too.
Jake: 可以
Jake: It works.
Jake: 紫藤来
Jake: Violet, come on.
Katrina:  补中
Katrina: Hit it!
Jake: 紫藤来
Jake: Violet, come on.
Shure:  是他
Shure: It's him.
Jake: 哎怎么这么多
Jake: Hey, why so many?
Tasha: 快
Tasha: Quick!
Shure:  完了要split了
Shure: Oh no, it's going to split.
Shure:  好全中
Shure: Alright, all hit.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Jake: 还有是吧
Jake: There's more, right?
Jake: 还有克星还有吧
Jake: There's more nemesis, right?
Jake: 还有还有还有可心呢
Jake: And, and, and what about Kexin?
Lucia: 还有吗还有哎又出来了
Lucia: Is there more? Oh, here it comes again.
Katrina:  几个币啊
Katrina: How many coins?
Jake: 呵一个一个一个
Jake: Haha, one, one, one.
Lucia: 怎么回事啊哈哈哈
Lucia: What's going on? Hahaha.
Lucia: 他会让我再再扔一次吗
Lucia: Will he let me throw it again?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 那我就再把这一个打中呗
Lucia: Then I'll just hit this one.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 稳稳健
Jake: Steady.
Katrina:  哇感觉可以
Katrina: Wow, feels like I can do it.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yeah!
Lucia: 他应该会还有一局
Lucia: There should be one more round.
Lucia: 我怎么感觉
Lucia: I feel like...
Tasha: 没有了啊
Tasha: No, it's over.
Jake: 没了没了就结束了
Jake: It's over, it's over, we're done.
Jake: 好走吧
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Jake: 还有两个币
Jake: There are two coins left.
Jake: 两个币就钱生钱吗
Jake: Two coins to make more money?
Jake: 对对对对钱生钱
Tasha: 是金钱的声音
Tasha: It's the sound of money.
Jake: 哇
Jake: Wow.
Jake: 天呐
Jake: Oh my god.
Shure:  教你们技巧
Shure: I'll teach you the trick.
Shure:  他他他伸进去
Shure: He, he, he puts it in.
Tasha: 伸进去时再放
Tasha: Put it in and then release.
Tasha: 放呀
Tasha: Release it.
Tasha: 放在哪了
Tasha: Where did you put it?
Lucia: 哦你按他才会释放好像
Lucia: Oh, you press it to release, I think.
Tasha: 好石沉大海
Tasha: Okay, it sank like a stone.
Shure:  嗯再来一个我们
Shure: Hmm, let's try another one.
Jake: 这是蝴蝶效应
Jake: This is the butterfly effect.
Lucia: 放进去
Lucia: Put it in.
Lucia: 然后按一下他才会掉下来
Lucia: Then press it to make it fall.
Lucia: 按微微按哈哈
Lucia: Press gently, haha.
Shure:  okay放
Shure: Okay, release.
Katrina:  啊就这么玩吗
Katrina: Ah, is this how you play?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Lucia: 好像叠住了哈哈
Lucia: Seems like it got stuck, haha.
Katrina:  走吧就这么玩的吗
Katrina: Are we just playing like this?
Jake: 走吧哈哈哈
Jake: Let's go, haha.
Katrina:  就掉下去
Katrina: Just drop down.
Jake: 走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Jake: 怎么还有拍一把
Jake: Why is there another shot?
Tasha: 它掉下来了
Tasha: It fell down.
Tasha: 啊它掉下来了我刚刚把它拍下来了
Tasha: Ah, it fell down. I just knocked it down.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Tasha: 它那怎么不掉呢
Tasha: Why didn't that one fall?
Tasha: 你看我刚刚把它
Tasha: Look, I just...
Jake: 我们如果再有一个币他就嗨了
Jake: If we had another coin, he'd be excited.
Tasha: 真的吗啊但是没有
Tasha: Really? But we don't have one.
Tasha: 我刚想我不是把它这样拍下来了吗
Tasha: I just thought, didn't I knock it down like this?
Jake: 不是你你拍下来他掉下来
Jake: No, you knocked it down, it fell.
Jake: 但是你投币了
Jake: But you put a coin in.
Tasha: 你看他们选错篮子了
Tasha: Look, they picked the wrong basket.
Tasha: 应该让我先把全部的机器拍一拍
Tasha: I should have knocked all the machines first.
Tasha: 然后再开始投币
Tasha: Then start putting coins in.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake: 投一个币得一个币哎哎哎
Jake: Put in a coin, get a coin. Hey, hey, hey.
Tasha: 哎哎哎连吃带拿
Tasha: Hey, hey, hey. Take and eat.
Tasha: 刚刚有人问我们在干嘛
Tasha: Someone just asked what we were doing.
Tasha: 我说
Tasha: I said
Tasha: 我们是一群机器人在模仿真人生活
Tasha: We are a group of robots imitating human life.
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Tasha: 你觉得他会相信吗
Tasha: Do you think he believed it?
Jake: 会
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 你觉得你相信了吗
Tasha: Do you think you believed it?
Jake: 我信了
Jake: I believed it.
Tasha: 好哈哈
Tasha: Good, haha.
Jake: 我们就是这是
Jake: We are just, this is...
Tasha: 我根本就没有跟别人说话
Tasha: I didn't actually talk to anyone.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 我只是在模拟
Tasha: I was just simulating.
Tasha: 万一有人问我们怎么办
Tasha: What if someone asks us?
Jake: 好吧从头就开始这编的
Jake: Okay, let's start from the beginning, this was made up.
Lucia: 如果你喜欢逛博物馆的话
Lucia: If you like visiting museums
Lucia: 可以去碑林博物馆还有闪丽博
Lucia: You can go to the Forest of Stone Steles Museum and Shanli Museum
Lucia: 还有西安博物馆
Lucia: And also the Xi'an Museum.
Lucia: 但是闪丽博好像这两年比较火
Lucia: But Shanli Museum has been popular in recent years.
Lucia: 然后就特别难约票
Lucia: So it's especially hard to get tickets.
Lucia: 就要提前几天开始约票才行
Lucia: You have to start booking tickets a few days in advance.
Lucia: 但是这几个
Lucia: But these few
Lucia: 碑林博物馆好像是要门票的
Lucia: The Beilin Museum seems to require tickets.
Tasha: 哦对不起
Tasha: Oh, sorry.
Lucia: 但是闪丽博和西安博物馆都是免费的
Lucia: But the Shannxi History Museum and Xi'an Museum are free.
Lucia: 就只要预约就行
Lucia: You just need to make a reservation.
Tasha: 然后干嘛去
Tasha: Then what do we do next?
Tasha: 哎你看我买帽子的地方
Tasha: Hey, look at where I bought my hat.
Lucia: 这就是那天那个的green party
Lucia: This is from that green party the other day.
Jake: 哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Jake: 挺好玩这些小孩
Jake: These kids are pretty fun.
Lucia: 为什么现在会有这么多室内的
Lucia: Why are there so many indoor
Lucia: 这样的篮球场
Lucia: Basketball courts now?
Lucia: 篮球不应该在室外打吗
Lucia: Isn't basketball meant to be played outdoors?
Tasha: 可能帅吧
Tasha: Maybe it's cooler this way.
Lucia: 哈哈有道理哈哈
Lucia: Haha, makes sense. Haha.
Jake: 对是一样
Jake: Yeah, it's the same.
Jake: 能室内就室内
Jake: If you can play indoors, then play indoors.
Tasha: 现在干嘛去
Tasha: What do we do now?
Tasha: 怎么人不见了
Tasha: Where did everyone go?
Jake: 对啊他们人呢
Jake: Yeah, where did they go?
Jake: 剩下的人去哪了呢
Jake: Where did the rest of them go?
Tasha: 觉得我们先逛个超市吧
Tasha: I think we should visit a supermarket first.
Jake: 好走走
Jake: Okay, let's go.
Jake: 晃悠晃悠
Jake: Let's wander around.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun dun dun dun.
Tasha: 哦果然他们已经开始买了
Tasha: Oh, looks like they already started shopping.
Jake: 好玩吗有肉吗
Jake: Is it fun? Do they have meat?
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure:  这这是一个
Shure: This is a
Jake: 啥呀这都是
Jake: What is all this?
Shure:  超级特价超市
Shure: Super discount supermarket.
Jake: 噢噢噢
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Shure:  杨老板逛过吗
Shure: Have you been to one, Jake?
Jake: 没有那
Jake: No, I haven't.
Tasha: 看才三块三
Tasha: Look, it's only 3.3 yuan.
Shure:  新加坡有有
Shure: Do they have these in Singapore?
Shure:  有这种的吗
Shure: Do they have these?
Jake: 3块3的牙刷好有
Jake: 3.3 yuan toothbrushes? Yeah, they do.
Jake: 好像没有一元
Jake: I don't think they have anything for 1 yuan though.
Jake: 问到就是那种什么刀了
Jake: Asking about what kind of knife it is.
Jake: 都有什么比较优秀的便宜的东西呢
Jake: What are some good and cheap things?
Tasha: 重新买一瓶
Tasha: Buy a new bottle.
Lucia: 不知道我也只逛过一次
Lucia: I don't know, I've only been there once.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 3块9的巴黎矿泉水早上
Jake: 3.9 yuan for Paris mineral water in the morning.
Jake: 应该再整点这个对
Jake: Should get some more of this, right.
Lucia: 哦这个这个
Lucia: Oh, this one.
Lucia: 在这里卖的还挺便宜的嘛
Lucia: It's quite cheap here.
Shure:  确实 12块5呢
Shure: Indeed, it's 12.5 yuan.
Lucia: 这在国国内有地方卖老贵
Lucia: It's very expensive in some places back home.
Lucia: 呃卖老贵
Lucia: Uh, very expensive.
Jake: 哦真的呀 12块5
Jake: Oh really? 12.5 yuan?
Shure:  星巴克那玻璃那个更贵巴黎水
Shure: The glass bottled one at Starbucks is even more expensive.
Katrina:  微便宜啊两块钱
Katrina: Slightly cheaper, 2 yuan.
Shure:  啊确实
Shure: Ah, true.
其他人：我也想买一瓶别的东西
Others: I also want to buy something else.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 没有水我的水丢了
Tasha: There's no water, I lost mine.
Jake: 对我我我买的那个10个USB的充电器
Jake: Yeah, I bought that 10-port USB charger.
Jake: 也3030多块钱一个
Jake: It was over 30 yuan each.
Lucia: 我们俩打开
Lucia: We both opened it.
Lucia: 不知道接下来怎么处理
Lucia: Don't know what to do next.
Lucia: 他就放在那
Lucia: It just sat there.
Lucia: 就过一会他嘣哈哈哈
Lucia: After a while, it went bang, hahaha.
Jake: 哦延时崩
Jake: Oh, it delayed and then exploded.
Shure:  还有什么想买的吗Minasa
Shure: Anything else you want to buy, Minasa?
Jake: 还有啥好东西
Jake: Any other good stuff?
Shure:  你知道黄桃黄桃罐头吗
Shure: Do you know about canned yellow peaches?
Jake: 我知道治感冒的
Jake: I know they can cure colds.
Katrina:  买点小零食当那个
Katrina: Buy some snacks for that.
Jake: 就跟拜佛似的也治感冒
Jake: It's like praying to Buddha, it can cure colds.
Shure:  这不是野餐零食吗哈哈
Shure: Aren't these picnic snacks? Haha.
Tasha: 噔噔噔这个糖还挺好吃的
Tasha: Ta-da, this candy is pretty good.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  一块钱
Shure: One yuan.
Alice:啥呀
Alice: What?
Katrina:  一块钱不在话下
Katrina: One yuan, no big deal.
Alice:什么玩意
Alice: What is it?
Tasha: 不在话下薄荷糖
Tasha: No problem at all, mint candy
Tasha: 哦结你
Tasha: Oh, did you settle it?
Tasha: 你结过账了是吧
Tasha: You already paid, right?
Katrina:  我没有我买的是自己的东西
Katrina: No, I bought my own stuff.
Katrina:  他们还没结呢
Katrina: They haven't paid yet.
Shure:  这样我们我们都给杨老板换
Shure: So, we all change it for Jake.
Shure:  换算成新币
Shure: Convert it to new currency.
Shure:  咱们都对
Shure: We're all good.
Alice:这样听起来就不心疼了哈哈
Alice: That way it doesn't feel so painful, haha.
Jake: 这个太离谱了吧 5毛星
Jake: This is outrageous, 50 cents.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake: 5毛钱的新币
Jake: 50 cents of new currency.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Jake: 什么东西
Jake: What is it?
Shure:  3块9就5毛钱是吗
Shure: 3.9 is just 50 cents, right?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun.
Shure:  你就除以5减3
Shure: You just divide by 5 and subtract 3.
Shure:  你大概除以5
Shure: Roughly divide by 5.
Shure:  然后再减去抹个0就对了
Shure: Then subtract and round to zero, that's about right.
Jake: 对给我报新币吧
Jake: Yeah, give me the new currency rate.
Jake: 你这多少钱这
Jake: How much is this?
Jake: 呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehe.
Shure:  听个响还能
Shure: Just to hear the sound.
Jake: 还来听个响
Jake: Just to hear the sound again.
Katrina:  OK了
Katrina: OK, done.
Lucia: 好像也还行
Lucia: Seems alright too.
Lucia: 奥迪和丽豆里面应该有不少这个价格
Lucia: Audi and Lidl should have a lot of items at this price.
Lucia: 你们那有奥迪和丽豆
Lucia: Do you have Audi and Lidl there?
Katrina:  欧了欧了
Katrina: Oh yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 怎么买OK
Lucia: How to buy it, OK.
Jake: 但是七新币听起来就很便宜
Jake: But 7 new currency sounds really cheap.
Alice:这个牌子小啤酒
Alice: This brand of small beer.
Shure:  懂了懂了
Shure: Got it, got it.
Shure:  这这多少
Shure: How much is this?
Shure:  这不到1新币
Shure: It's less than 1 new currency.
Shure:  这这一袋那什么
Shure: This bag of what?
Lucia: 呃body shop是一个英国牌子
Lucia: Uh, Body Shop is a British brand.
Alice:嗯这边破产了
Alice: Yeah, it's bankrupt here.
Shure:  然后他
Shure: And then he...
Shure:  他还拿了一个不到两两毛新币的
Shure: He also took one that cost less than 20 cents.
Alice:清仓
Alice: Clearance sale.
Shure:  一个薄荷糖
Shure: A mint candy.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  哇以后就都给杨老板报新币
Shure: Wow, from now on, let's report everything to Jake in new dollars.
Lucia: 那我买了瓶饮料可以吗
Lucia: So, can I buy a drink?
Lucia: 虽然我是自己喝
Lucia: Even if it's just for myself.
Lucia: 不过大概也就5毛新币吧
Lucia: It should be about 50 cents.
Tasha: 按5毛新币
Tasha: 50 cents, got it.
Lucia: 5毛新币
Lucia: 50 cents.
Tasha: 新币的换算比例是除五再抹个0
Tasha: The conversion rate for new dollars is divide by 5 and then round down.
Shure:  嗯除以5再抹个0
Shure: Yeah, divide by 5 and round down.
Shure:  对他说大概是5.3
Shure: He said it's roughly 5.3.
Katrina:  放我这袋里吧
Katrina: Put it in my bag.
Jake: 多少新币
Jake: How much in new dollars?
Jake: 10块
Jake: 10 bucks.
Tasha: 十个金
Tasha: Ten gold coins.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure:  52块4不到1新币
Shure: 52.4 is less than 1 new dollar.
Tasha: 一个新币
Tasha: One new dollar.
Shure:  不行杨老板咱先别换算呵呵
Shure: No, Jake, let's not do the conversion for now, haha.
Jake: 怎么付啊
Jake: How do we pay?
Katrina:  放我这袋里吧
Katrina: Put it in my bag.
Lucia: 这方法会不会有点重啊
Lucia: Isn't this method a bit heavy?
Katrina:  party没关系
Katrina: It's okay for the party.
Lucia: 哦你提啊
Lucia: Oh, you're carrying it?
Lucia: 那那就放了
Lucia: Alright, then put it in.
Lucia: 那我就不客气了啊哈哈
Lucia: I won't be polite then, haha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈没事
Katrina: Hahaha, it's fine.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Shure:  留好小票子
Shure: Keep the receipt.
Katrina:  走吧盒马在哪呢
Katrina: Let's go, where's Hema?
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 来干正事吧
Jake: Let's get down to business.
Jake: 可以哎我看看还能录多久啊
Jake: Okay, let me see how much longer we can record.
Alice:啊一个小时
Alice: About an hour.
Jake: 行那正好
Jake: Great, perfect.
Jake: 正事能干一小时吗
Jake: Can we get the business done in an hour?
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 玩具吧
Tasha: Toys, right?
Jake: 买肉买肉可能用不着一小时
Jake: Buying meat, buying meat might not take an hour.
Jake: 买肉用不着一小时
Jake: Buying meat doesn't need an hour.
Jake: 再晃一晃
Jake: Just shake it again.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake: 他当场切肉是吗
Jake: Does he cut the meat on the spot?
Shure:  不是我回去处理的时候
Shure: No, I handle it when I get back.
Jake: 你回去处理
Jake: You handle it when you get back.
Jake: 充完电了就重来了
Jake: Once it's charged, we'll start over again.
Jake: 就重来了呀
Jake: We'll start over again.
Jake: 就不是这一波了
Jake: It won't be this batch.
Tasha: 哦我已经看到他了
Tasha: Oh, I already see him.
Shure:  我也看到他了
Shure: I see him too.
Shure:  我看到了他的倒影
Shure: I see his reflection.
Jake: 谁啊哦
Jake: Who? Oh.
Shure:  在反转世界在镜花水月中
Shure: In the reverse world, in the illusion.
Shure:  我已经看到了他
Shure: I already saw him.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Tasha: 几米是什么
Tasha: What does "few meters" mean?
Tasha: 好吧什么都不是
Tasha: Okay, it's nothing.
Shure:  要不给他给它 喂个剪头素材
Shure: How about giving him some footage to edit?
Shure:  我牺牲一下
Shure: I'll sacrifice a bit.
Alice:生瓜子的味道
Alice: The taste of raw sunflower seeds.
Alice:炒瓜子啊
Alice: Roasted sunflower seeds.
Jake: 嗯糊了炒糊了
Jake: Hmm, it's burnt, over-roasted.
Tasha: 拿拿车车呀
Tasha: Take the car, yeah.
Jake: 好糊啊
Jake: It's really burnt.
Jake: 几车一车够了吧
Jake: One car should be enough, right?
Tasha: 可能吧
Tasha: Probably.
Jake: 大家就觉得北京只有盒马
Jake: Everyone thinks Beijing only has Hema.
Tasha: 还有山姆物美
Tasha: There's also Sam's Club and Wu Mart.
Jake: 哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Tasha: 是不是要买很多羊肉粒牛肉粒
Tasha: Do we need to buy a lot of mutton and beef cubes?
Alice:他是不是还要买枪啊
Alice: Does he also need to buy a gun?
Tasha: 签谁买了呗你不说
Tasha: Who bought the sign? You didn't say.
Jake: 哦是那边有吧估计
Jake: Oh, it's probably over there.
Lucia: 可能有一次性的那种竹签对
Lucia: Maybe there are disposable bamboo sticks, right.
Alice:中间有没有直接带圈的
Alice: Are there any that come with rings in the middle?
Jake: 签签签怎么整啊
Jake: How to handle the sticks?
Shure:  这显得就很没用你知道吗
Shure: This just seems useless, you know?
Jake: 那你干啥呀
Jake: Then what are you doing?
Lucia: 这有穿好的还有签
Lucia: There are already some skewers ready, and some with the signature.
Jake: 哈哈哈没有签
Jake: Hahaha, no signature.
Alice:这不是有穿好的吗
Alice: Aren't there some ready ones?
Lucia: 所有的问题都解决了
Lucia: All the problems are solved.
Shure:  不咱们买点鸡翅
Shure: No, let's buy some chicken wings.
Shure:  我腌的鸡翅特别好吃
Shure: The chicken wings I marinate are super tasty.
Jake: 行整点整点
Jake: Alright, let's get some, let's get some.
Tasha: 这个要拿吗
Tasha: Should we take this?
Shure:  要拿吗也拿点这个
Shure: Should we take it? Yeah, let's take some of this too.
Jake: 拿点拿点拿点
Jake: Take some, take some, take some.
Shure:  好吧就是咱们得保证一个饿不死的
Shure: Okay, we just need to make sure we won't starve.
Tasha: 羊肉
Tasha: Lamb.
Shure:  一个食食物
Shure: Some food.
Shure:  然后在在死之上
Shure: And then we can survive.
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Lucia: 啊这是羊排吗
Lucia: Ah, is this lamb rib?
Shure:  我靠羊排
Shure: Wow, lamb rib.
Shure:  然后可以憋
Shure: And then we can hold on.
Tasha: 一个新币
Tasha: One new dollar.
Tasha: 加起来一共两个新币
Tasha: Totaling two new dollars.
Jake: 买买两个新币在新加坡就有半根串
Jake: Buying two new dollars in Singapore gets you half a skewer.
Katrina:  真的吗这么贵
Katrina: Really? That expensive?
Jake: 哈哈真的是的
Jake: Haha, it really is.
Lucia: 10新币
Lucia: 10 new dollars.
Shure:  五十九十新币
Shure: 50, 90 new dollars.
Shure:  你怎么算的哈哈
Shure: How did you calculate that? Haha.
Jake: 4新币 4新币
Jake: 4 new dollars, 4 new dollars.
其他人：算成50:1了
Others: It was calculated as 50:1.
Tasha: 这5:1吗 5:1
Tasha: Is it 5:1? 5:1.
Lucia: 哈 5比5点多
Lucia: Haha, 5 to a bit more than 5.
Jake: 对大概一根串
Jake: Yeah, about one skewer.
Jake: 就牛肉串
Jake: Just beef skewer.
Lucia: 为了方便可以先按5算
Lucia: To make it easy, we can count it as 5.
Jake: 这种牛肉串
Jake: This kind of beef skewer.
Jake: 大概就是哎这种串
Jake: It's about, yeah, this kind of skewer.
Jake: 一一新币一个
Jake: One new dollar each.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake: 一新币一串
Jake: One new dollar per skewer.
Jake: 对一新币一串
Jake: Yeah, one new dollar per skewer.
Jake: 位置好一点就两新币一串
Jake: If the location is better, it's two dollars per skewer.
Katrina:  这也给你腌好了
Katrina: I've already marinated this for you.
Katrina:  怎么办呢
Katrina: What should we do?
Shure:  不行我这不不需要不需要
Shure: No, we don't need this.
Shure:  咱们不用这些
Shure: We don't use these.
Shure:  这这些肯定不好吃
Shure: These definitely won't taste good.
Katrina:  你有自己独家配方来腌吗
Katrina: Do you have your own special marinade recipe?
Katrina:  还是怎么
Katrina: Or what?
Shure:  是的祖传十八辈了已经
Shure: Yes, it's been passed down for eighteen generations.
Katrina:  那你需要买什么调料吗
Katrina: Do you need to buy any spices?
Jake: 哎肉买完了吗
Jake: Hey, did you finish buying the meat?
Jake: 还没开始呢
Jake: Not yet.
Lucia: 内含三种口味
Lucia: It comes in three flavors.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun.
Tasha: 嘟嘟嘟嘟
Tasha: Doo doo doo doo.
Tasha: pick me
Tasha: Pick me.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun.
Tasha: 噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun.
Tasha: 嗯嗯嗯嗯
Tasha: Mmm mmm mmm mmm.
Tasha: 脚好痛啊
Tasha: My feet hurt.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun.
Tasha: pick me
Tasha: Pick me.
Tasha: 什么玩意
Tasha: What is this?
Tasha: 猜猜为什么要买鸡蛋
Tasha: Guess why we need to buy eggs.
Jake: 因为不够了
Jake: Because we ran out.
Tasha: 对因为鸡蛋消耗比例太大啊
Tasha: Yeah, because we use up eggs really quickly.
Lucia: 哦那天
Lucia: Oh, that day.
Jake: 今天还要做甜点
Jake: We're making desserts today.
Jake: 你要多少
Jake: How many do you need?
Tasha: 啊鸡蛋吗
Tasha: Ah, eggs?
Jake: 啊你要
Jake: Yeah, you need...
Tasha: 一次甜品可能要10个鸡蛋吧
Tasha: Maybe around 10 eggs for one dessert.
Jake: 你还缺多少啊
Jake: How many are you short?
Jake: 好嘞你还缺什么吗
Jake: Alright, do you need anything else?
Jake: 今儿
Jake: Today
Tasha: 我不缺什么
Tasha: I don't need anything
Lucia: 今天这个应该够
Lucia: This should be enough for today
Jake: 今天做什么呀
Jake: What are we doing today
Lucia: 哪怕在就是意外消耗应该也够了
Lucia: Even if there's unexpected consumption, it should be enough
Tasha: 今天做什么
Tasha: What are we doing today
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Tasha: 都可以啊
Tasha: Anything is fine
Jake: oh好
Jake: Oh, okay
Tasha: 你想吃什么
Tasha: What do you want to eat
Jake: 那就选一个
Jake: Then just pick one
Jake: 在众多图片里边选一个
Jake: Pick one from all the pictures
Tasha: 买点sweet drink吧
Tasha: Let's buy some sweet drinks
Lucia: 可以呀我都可以
Lucia: Sure, I'm fine with anything
Lucia: 看你想喝啥
Lucia: Depends on what you want to drink
其他人：好累呀
Others: So tired
Tasha: 我也是脚都坐痛了
Tasha: Me too, my feet are sore from sitting
Lucia: 我我的本体是一只树懒
Lucia: My true form is a sloth
Tasha: 他更像
Tasha: He's more like one
Jake: 动作太快了
Jake: Moving too fast
Jake: 我怎么就树懒了呀
Jake: How did I become a sloth
Lucia: 没有他是卡皮吧啦
Lucia: No, he's a capybara
Jake: 那是啥
Jake: What's that
Lucia: 情绪稳定啊
Lucia: Very calm
Lucia: 你不知道这个梗吗
Lucia: Don't you know this meme
Jake: 不知道
Jake: No idea
Lucia: 这是水豚
Lucia: It's a capybara
Lucia: 是一种很可爱的动物
Lucia: It's a very cute animal
Shure:  happy吧啦
Shure: Happy capybara
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 然后他就是情绪特别稳定
Lucia: And it's very calm emotionally
Lucia: 就是即使电脑的电线断了
Lucia: Even if the computer's power cord is cut
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 他也能就是情绪稳定的按住
Lucia: It can still stay calm and press the button
Shure:  肯定的爱
Shure: Definitely love it
Lucia: 直到把问题解决为止
Lucia: Until the problem is solved
Tasha: 又买土豆
Tasha: Buying potatoes again
其他人：不买土豆啊
Others: No potatoes
Tasha: 买
Tasha: Buy them
Shure:  可以烤点
Shure: We can roast some
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Tasha: 烤点
Tasha: Roast a bit
Shure:  想想啊咱们是7个人
Shure: Think about it, we are seven people
Jake: 这样你吃不了
Jake: This way, you can't eat it
Jake: 其他人：
Jake: Anyone else?
Shure:  是7个人吃是吧
Shure: Seven people eating, right?
Tasha: 那要不要买那个烤料
Tasha: Should we buy the grilling spices?
Tasha: 烤烧烤料
Tasha: Barbecue spices
Shure:  是的我先算一下肉要多些
Shure: Yes, let me calculate how much meat we need
Shure:  这么多鸡蛋
Shure: So many eggs
Lucia: 这薇薇要做甜点要用
Lucia: Tasha needs them for making desserts
Shure:  啊那一会借我两个
Shure: Ah, then lend me two later
Tasha: 不借哈哈哈哈
Tasha: No lending, hahaha
Lucia: 哦你要糊那个啥是吗
Lucia: Oh, you need them for something, right?
Shure:  要要烟的话会
Shure: Yes, for marinating
Tasha: 要腌
Tasha: For marinating
Lucia: 要腌哦OK
Lucia: For marinating, okay
Tasha: 东西要用嗯
Tasha: We need to use them, yeah
Lucia: 我以为要往上面裹汁嘞
Lucia: I thought you were going to coat them with sauce
Shure:  对洋葱
Shure: Yes, onions
Tasha: 洋葱在这里就有
Tasha: Onions are right here
Lucia: 洋葱在这里就有
Shure:  我先算算一下肉的肉的量
Shure: Let me first calculate the amount of meat
Jake: 哦真远
Jake: Oh, really far
Shure:  我要紫皮洋葱
Shure: I need purple onions
Shure:  紫皮洋葱
Shure: Purple onions
Jake: 这个很紫啊
Jake: This one's really purple
Lucia: 紫的这种的呗
Lucia: The purple kind, right?
Jake: 这边啊
Jake: Over here
Alice:这个有机的
Alice: This one's organic
Jake: 有机多少钱
Jake: How much is the organic one?
Tasha: 没关系我们就吃贵的
Tasha: Doesn't matter, we'll just eat the expensive one
Lucia: 要大的还是小的
Lucia: Do you want big ones or small ones?
Jake: 有机多少钱
Jake: How much is the organic one?
Tasha: 我觉得要小的比较
Tasha: I think small ones are better
Tasha: 呃要三个小的比较好
Tasha: Uh, three small ones would be good
Tasha: 这样子的话就不会浪费
Tasha: This way, there won't be any waste
Lucia: 400克
Lucia: 400 grams
Lucia: 5块9 这个是那个类
Lucia: 5.9, this is that kind
Jake: 这多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Shure:  一新币这个
Shure: One dollar for this.
Jake: 这多少钱半新币
Jake: How much is this, half a dollar?
Shure:  4块3 我们差别
Shure: 4.3 dollars. We have a difference.
Jake: 那没差别
Jake: There's no difference.
Jake: 有机
Jake: Organic.
Tasha: 没差别
Tasha: No difference.
Jake: 哈哈啊就差一块钱
Jake: Haha, just a dollar difference.
Shure:  啊但是这个比那个轻 100克
Shure: But this one is 100 grams lighter.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  够了这些
Shure: That's enough.
Shure:  然后肉的话一斤一斤半
Shure: And for the meat, a pound and a half.
Alice:需要土豆什么吗
Alice: Do you need potatoes or anything?
Alice:土豆生菜
Alice: Potatoes, lettuce.
Shure:  然后底下那些串
Shure: And those skewers below.
Alice:生菜
Alice: Lettuce.
Tasha: pick me pick me pick pick pick pick
Tasha: Pick me, pick me, pick, pick, pick, pick.
Tasha: pick pick me pick pick pick me pick pick pick
Tasha: Pick, pick me, pick, pick, pick me, pick, pick, pick.
Tasha: 皮卡皮卡皮卡皮卡
Tasha: Pika, pika, pika, pika.
Tasha: 皮卡
Tasha: Pika.
Tasha: 皮卡皮卡皮卡皮卡皮卡皮卡皮卡皮卡
Tasha: Pika, pika, pika, pika, pika, pika, pika, pika.
Tasha: 皮卡皮卡
Tasha: Pika, pika.
Tasha: 皮卡皮卡皮卡皮卡皮卡皮卡皮卡皮卡
Tasha: Pika, pika, pika, pika, pika, pika, pika, pika.
Tasha: 皮卡皮卡
Tasha: Pika, pika.
Tasha: 买个西瓜吗皮卡皮卡皮卡皮卡皮卡
Tasha: Buy a watermelon? Pika, pika, pika, pika, pika.
Jake:看买
Jake: Let's see.
Tasha: 有没有切的人呀
Tasha: Is there anyone who can cut it?
Tasha: big PICO PICO PICO me PICO me
Tasha: Big PICO PICO PICO me, PICO me.
Tasha: 可以切个西瓜吗
Tasha: Can someone cut a watermelon?
Tasha: 我没找着切东西的人
Tasha: I can't find anyone to cut it.
Tasha: 在哪里可以切东西
Tasha: Where can I cut something?
Tasha: 你好在哪里可以切水果
Tasha: Hi, where can I cut fruit?
其他人：切不了水果您要什么水果啊
Others: We can't cut fruit. What fruit do you want?
Tasha: 西瓜
Tasha: Watermelon.
Jake: 看中啥了呀看中啥了呀
Jake: What caught your eye? What caught your eye?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 他不帮我切
Tasha: He won't cut it for me.
Tasha: 我不要了
Tasha: I don't want it anymore.
Jake: 好的他为什么不帮你切这
Jake: Okay, why won't he cut it for you?
Jake: 瓜为什么这么方啊
Jake: Why is this watermelon so square?
Tasha: 这有半个的
Tasha: Here's half of it.
Jake: 这瓜为什么这么方啊
Jake: Why is this melon so square?
Tasha: 他长得开心吧
Tasha: Maybe it grew happily.
Jake: 好丑啊
Jake: It's so ugly.
Jake: 半个颜色一般哦
Jake: The color of half is just okay.
Tasha: 但不知道没切开
Tasha: But we don't know until it's cut open.
Jake: 但这个好大呀
Jake: But this one is huge.
Tasha: 你买吗
Tasha: Are you buying it?
Jake: 山竹
Jake: Mangosteen.
Tasha: 20块钱
Tasha: 20 yuan.
Jake: 20块钱
Jake: 20 yuan.
Jake: 可以买
Jake: I can buy it.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Tasha: 但我不吃
Tasha: But I don't eat it.
Tasha: 你可以买
Tasha: You can buy it.
Tasha: 他们可能也吃
Tasha: Maybe they will eat it.
Jake: 那我买一个吧
Jake: Then I'll buy one.
Tasha: 好你会挑吗
Tasha: Alright, do you know how to pick?
Jake: 哟我我我就知道
Jake: Oh, I, I, I just know to pick the big ones.
Jake: 挑大的
Jake: The big ones.
Tasha: 我觉得这个好
Tasha: I think this one is good.
Jake:好 行听你的
Jake: Okay, I'll listen to you.
Tasha: 因为我觉得这个7个
Tasha: Because I think this one has seven pieces.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 那你还要别的水果吗
Jake: Do you want any other fruit?
Tasha: 我不要了
Tasha: I don't want any more.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 他们人了
Tasha: They are here.
Jake: 他们人呢
Jake: Where are they?
Tasha: 去买小甜水吧
Tasha: Let's go buy some sweet water.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 吃榴莲吗
Tasha: Do you eat durian?
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Hehe.
Jake: 榴莲披萨
Jake: Durian pizza.
Jake: 可以吃榴莲
Jake: We can eat durian.
Tasha: 榴莲你不吃啊
Tasha: You don't eat durian?
Jake: 榴莲也可以吃榴莲
Jake: We can eat durian too.
Jake: 可以吃但是
Jake: We can eat it, but...
Jake: 买吧98
Jake: Let's buy it, 98 yuan.
Tasha: 算了吧
Tasha: Forget it.
Tasha: 要不有那种小的
Tasha: Or maybe there's a smaller one.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Tasha: 小的
Tasha: A smaller one.
Jake: 哦榴莲可以吃吗
Jake: Oh, can we eat durian?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake: 小的是什么
Jake: What's the smaller one?
Tasha: 看到这里有一个这个
Tasha: Look, there's one here.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 嗯你吃的话就可以买一盒
Tasha: Hmm, if you eat it, you can buy one box.
Tasha: 我吃的话就可以买一盒
Tasha: If I eat it, we can buy one box.
Jake: 好那就买一盒
Jake: Okay, then let's buy one box.
Tasha: 因为好像只有两个人吃
Tasha: Because it seems like only two people are eating.
Tasha: 今天中午的榴莲披萨
Tasha: Today's durian pizza for lunch.
Jake: 哦这么回事啊
Jake: Oh, that's what's going on.
Tasha: 哈哈他们都不吃
Tasha: Haha, they all don't eat it.
Jake: 那买吧买吧买吧好的
Jake: Then buy it, buy it, buy it, okay.
Tasha: 那就买两个嘛
Tasha: Then let's buy two.
Tasha: 好呀
Tasha: Okay.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 他们在哪呢
Jake: Where are they?
Jake: 你的小甜水呢
Jake: Where's your sweet drink?
Tasha: 这呢
Tasha: Here it is.
Tasha: 哎我看到学姐了
Tasha: Oh, I saw the senior.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 我听说这个很好喝
Tasha: I heard this one is really good.
Tasha: 就是我在想买大瓶的还是买这样子的
Tasha: I'm just wondering if I should buy a big bottle or this size.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 所以呢
Tasha: So?
Jake: 买大瓶的吧
Jake: Buy the big bottle.
Tasha: 那就买一瓶吧
Tasha: Then let's buy one bottle.
Jake: 对小瓶的
Jake: Yeah, the small bottle.
Jake: 不知道谁是喝不完的
Jake: I don't know, who can't finish it?
Jake: 大瓶的能喝完
Jake: The big bottle can be finished.
Tasha: 买什么
Tasha: What to buy?
Jake: 买帝王蟹啊
Jake: Buy king crab.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake: 没有买买油买油
Jake: No, buy oil, buy oil.
Tasha: 可是不是有玉玉米油吗
Tasha: But isn't there corn oil?
Tasha: 玉米油不符合他们的要求是吧
Tasha: Corn oil doesn't meet their requirements, right?
Tasha: 泡茶的水
Tasha: Water for making tea.
Jake: 哎呀不好意思撞到你了
Jake: Oh, sorry for bumping into you.
Jake: 你去新加坡
Jake: Are you going to Singapore?
Jake: 上次谢斌竹去就哎
Jake: Last time, Xie Binzhu went...
Shure:  我靠没听过这个
Shure: Wow, I've never heard of that.
Alice:六婆这么有名的蘸料
Alice: Liupo's dipping sauce is so famous.
Jake: 100新币 100新币一只
Jake: 100 Singapore dollars, 100 Singapore dollars each.
Jake: 哈哈哈还行吧
Jake: Hahaha, not bad, right?
Jake: 100新币一只
Jake: 100 Singapore dollars each.
Katrina:  我买了一个冰淇
Katrina: I bought an ice cream.
Jake: 这个多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me take a look.
Lucia: 是是那天那个1,600块钱的帝王蟹吗
Lucia: Is it that 1,600 dollar king crab from the other day?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈不是
Jake: Hahaha, no.
Lucia: 还是啥
Lucia: Or what?
Shure:  换算除5的话不到100新币
Shure: If you divide by 5, it's less than 100 Singapore dollars.
Jake: 波龙在波士顿就十十美元
Jake: Lobsters in Boston are just ten, ten dollars.
Jake: 10美元一只
Jake: 10 dollars each.
Lucia: 哦那比在比在伦敦还便宜
Lucia: Oh, that's cheaper than in London.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake: 当时吃了一周就天天的买
Jake: We ate them for a week straight, buying them every day.
Jake: 然后吃腻了
Jake: Then we got tired of them.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake: 还缺什么呀
Jake: What else are we missing?
Jake: 明早让他们做个早饭
Jake: Let's have them make breakfast tomorrow morning.
Jake: 明早你们做个早饭吧
Jake: You guys make breakfast tomorrow morning.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake: 啊明早会做
Jake: Oh, will you make it tomorrow morning?
Jake: 明天明早做早饭吧
Jake: Let's make breakfast tomorrow morning.
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Sure.
Lucia: 可以做我们刚才是不是买了面包
Lucia: Can we do it? Didn't we buy bread just now?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 还是怎么回事来着
Lucia: Or how did it go again?
Jake: 对面包是要烤的啊还没对
Jake: Yes, the bread needs to be toasted. Right, it hasn't been...
Alice:面包还没买呢
Alice: We haven't bought the bread yet.
Tasha: 土司片是吗
Tasha: Sliced bread, right?
Katrina:  买个面包搞点番茄酱就行了
Katrina: Just buy some bread and get some ketchup, that's enough.
Tasha: 后再买点生菜
Tasha: Then buy some lettuce.
Tasha: 直接做个三明治
Tasha: And make a sandwich directly.
Alice:生菜有但是不知道够不够
Alice: We have lettuce, but I don't know if it's enough.
Tasha: 但是不知道够不够
Tasha: But I don't know if it's enough.
Katrina:  hamburger选手在
Katrina: The hamburger contestants are here.
Jake: 明天就在
Jake: They'll be here tomorrow.
Jake: 就就在屋里待着了
Jake: So just stay in the house.
Jake: 跳跳舞什么的
Jake: Maybe dance a bit.
Jake: 然后如果快递到了就整一整
Jake: And if the package arrives, we'll sort it out.
Katrina:  对明天主要快递会很多
Katrina: Yes, there will be a lot of packages tomorrow.
Lucia: 到这个我的快递为什么还没到
Lucia: Why hasn't my package arrived?
Lucia: 我在京东上买的东西
Lucia: I bought it on JD.com.
Lucia: 应该今天到啊
Lucia: It should've arrived today.
Jake: 好行行好的
Jake: Okay, sure, sure, okay.
Jake: 好可以好
Jake: Alright, sounds good.
其他人：那我先走了
Others: I'll head out first.
Katrina:  你要回去啊
Katrina: You're leaving?
其他人：我要赶紧回别墅拿东西
Others: I need to rush back to the villa to get some stuff.
Katrina:  打卡吗
Katrina: Are you clocking out?
Katrina:  拜拜拜拜
Katrina: Bye, bye.
Jake: 周日见周日来是吧
Jake: See you on Sunday, right?
Shure:  拜拜哦
Shure: Bye!
Jake: 拜拜
Jake: Bye.
Katrina:  好拜拜
Katrina: Okay, bye.
Shure:  那是咱们是6个人啊
Shure: So, there are six of us?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  那没事吃不了
Shure: No worries, we can't finish it.
Shure:  周日再弄吧
Shure: Let's do it on Sunday then.
Jake: 对可以好
Jake: Yes, sounds good.
Jake: 拜拜
Jake: Bye.
Katrina:  拜拜
Katrina: Bye.
Shure:  孜然哥我们还需要孜然
Shure: Cumin brother, we still need cumin.
Tasha: take me me pick a pick me
Tasha: Take me, me, pick a pick me.
Tasha:  pick pick me
Tasha: Pick, pick me.
Shure:  其实我们还可以弄点什么花蛤啥的
Shure: Actually, we can also get some clams or something.
Shure:  最重要的碳
Shure: The most important thing is the charcoal.
Shure:  对一会回去的路上咱们先把碳点着
Shure: Yeah, let's light the charcoal on the way back.
Jake: 可以喝三泡
Jake: We can have three rounds.
Jake: 谢谢你
Jake: Thank you.
Katrina:  可以搞这种小瓶酸奶放冰箱里
Katrina: We can put small bottles of yogurt in the fridge.
Katrina:  大家想喝就喝
Katrina: So anyone can drink if they want.
Jake: 这哪家呀
Jake: Which brand is this?
其他人：原价卖39的
Others: Originally priced at 39
其他人：现在22块9 特价的
Others: Now it's 22.9, on special
Lucia: 小瓶那像这种
Lucia: Small bottles like this
Lucia: 然后可以分装
Lucia: Then you can portion it out
Lucia: 我感觉这玩意好像也不便宜
Lucia: I feel like this thing isn't cheap either
Tasha: 喂
Tasha: Hello
Tasha: 嗯在逛超市呢咋了
Tasha: Yeah, I'm shopping at the supermarket, what's up?
Tasha: 我我手机都没响
Tasha: My phone didn't even ring
Tasha: 我没看到手机
Tasha: I didn't see my phone
Tasha: 嗯好的好的
Tasha: Okay, okay
Jake: 又在工作
Jake: Working again
Jake: 天天工作
Jake: Working every day